[Music]
it's right here
how come your [ __ ] feet could
disappeared like my soul this corn
person this week we've got another
disaster cartel takedown and street
justice
take it away Tiffany take it away take
it away you guys can't do this sort of
thing okay don't be mean alright so for
our first story Mexico was hit with two
earthquakes in less than two weeks is
your family okay uh my sister I sent her
a message recently she said they're
having because she's in one bed my dear
but like that doesn't in Mexico City she
didn't tell me where my dad's I haven't
hurry why is that where was hit Mexico
City that's where a lot of the damage
was done
mr. closes like big city right how big
was this earthquake this time
so the first earthquake happened on
September 8th it killed about 61 people
oh my god the 8.1 chances and then the
second one was on September 19th with
the magnitude of 7.1 it lasts about 20
seconds killing at least 226 people down
at least 200 they're still trying to
find survivors that day September 19 was
anniversary of a devastating earthquake
that happened back in 1985 that killed
4200 people
Bowser how big was that one that one was
eight point so this one it was more
prepared yeah the obstruction was better
god damn that's crazy
they were uh was two hours before the
the earthquake they were actually doing
yeah they were doing girls but to
celebrate their you gotta celebrate
we're like yeah and remembrance of that
previous earthquake they were doing
earthquake drills up do you think that
helped intronic like with the like the
death toll and stuff like that really it
was like they were actually doing the
drills and then
nice gonna bring some earthquake
rollercoaster just cuz like I want a
simulator yeah I want to feel what no I
want to feel what it feels like but I
don't want to be in danger or something
right maybe a fear that's like nothing
though it's like a big mom even if it
was like an eight it's like because
they're not trying to hurt you oh yeah
we did do it we've been on it's like an
elevator shaft and they just kind of
shake it lifting it's up to eight and
it's nothing I don't I don't remember
what what the scale of like what you can
do but like I just remember thinking oh
this is like very mild you know like if
you want to experience like an 8.1
magnitude I don't think you need all the
buildings around you nervous there was
uh there was we felt one here too like a
few days ago I wasn't it was a pretty
big shake apparently I didn't feel
anything yeah I didn't feel anything
either bad never thought it was like at
2:00 or 3:00 in the morning or something
right like almost every single
earthquake that we've experienced
everybody was tweeting Oh
earthquake sometimes I just tweet it
just cuz I want to be a part of the
group oh you feel that I'm like yeah I
think my body's like shock absorbing it
[ __ ] I really feel them too burritos
even as a kid I would hear things fall
off the wall and then and then I wake up
so it's like after the fact that my own
earthquake
the one time that I felt that a little
bit was during one of you guys just part
of thing meets and then it was like the
TV's were shaking everybody felt it oh
yeah there was a source it was yours we
just dropped a dumbbell no it was
actually way before I did anything dan
please it's so crazy - oh good I can't
remember who told me this story I feel
like it was a co-worker that of mine
back in the hospital but someone I know
it told me a story from that 1985
earthquake that their brother was
engaged to a doctor like he was going to
medical school and so him and his
fiancee they were at this hospital and
then the earthquake hit
the guy wasn't there but the fiancée was
you know getting killed you know my
hospital from that earthquake so
immediately when I heard about this I
thought about that story but I can't
remember who was that's up do that's so
sad and then like he never got over her
like he really married like he ended up
getting married to someone else but
pretty quick married like another week
to his other girl buzz and it was hard
for him know that person telling me that
story because telling me like he would
talk to his kids about that fat lady it
that's pretty sad that's a rebound
marriage all question good question
I've never might continue your story
because I'm gonna show you guys 30 I'm
gonna show you guys video clips oh oh do
I got to see what it looks hard flip our
powers now
how do they know that building was gonna
crash like they kept recording it yeah
we get that building what the dude in
that building you were just your dad
whoa do cover your head is that schools
cover your head it's a escuela
[Music]
oh my goodness how did they know that
the building was gonna fall they just
they're probably just recording see I
live on that corner and they're like
that buildings gonna go anything oh my
God look at how [ __ ] crazy that
shaking
damn that's just crazy never mind I
don't want to be on it right I wouldn't
want to even videotape like you're in
that moment like I do have some balls
getting their phone now and they're like
recording stuff I'd be running for a
survival yeah every building should be
earthquake-proof in California that
should just be a standard thing I think
okay nevermind smarted [ __ ] why LA
doesn't have like big skyscrapers until
recently yeah and then even the
skyscrapers the way they're built like
they have some sort of engineering cure
that [ __ ] out a gyroscope all like is it
like the ones in Asia the ones that we
saw in Taiwan they're different they're
more uh that's typhoon poof Oh cuz we
were at this of this one building
they're building they're showing the
bottom and there's a pendulum so in the
center of the building there's like this
big pendulum thing so if if like the
typhoon comes and pushes the building
the pendulum will prevent it from
falling down and it's like a big pool of
water just on top just for stability the
only ones have it how do they yeah it
was crazy technology everyone's saying
now what are you guys thinking like
everyone's saying now that would do for
one that's what everyone says right we
have been like free well yeah but we've
got the 5.1 so in my person this is not
science but I think it's like it's
blowing off a little steam pinky so we
might be farted a little bit like if you
hold any parties explodes they're right
near the
Andrea's fault dude we're on one right
now this little mountain that we're on
yeah crash your honor right now oh and
most of us live on the floor right like
none of us live George's we did right
but it's a new building a new building
so I hope that the building code is
earthquake by a [ __ ] parachute dude
and then you just [ __ ] shoot out your
window introduce maybe the squirrel ones
I don't know if the parachute would work
for the sixth floor okay find the
squirrel fits the ones that have that
that'd be fun you just fly out
oh my god if you put it on the dogs you
just go poop sheep turn them into bats
first area I don't okay so everyone's
saying at the earthquake survival kit
with the foods and stuff but what is the
point in that if a building is [ __ ]
collapses because they tell you to put
it in your car to to have food in your
car at all times
yeah like you will have a bag with like
extra clothes it's so expensive and then
a lot of the stuff expires after a while
and you know what I guess it's a good
idea to do what about at home though
like what if you keep it on your bed but
everything collapses it's under your bed
you can't lift anything so what's the
point I'm happy then you just start
[ __ ] mugging people apocalypse I mean
what else is either you were then I
gotta make sense in a car I can ask my
landlord if for the place of renting out
his like you know we should ask our
student oh my god imagine you imagine if
you guys you guys sell old building I am
but then I heard you guys and you guys
are saying all this [ __ ] I was thinking
and I'm like oh let me just bash know
you guys are actually prepared for
certain things I say I've seen your
house you guys are prepared for some
[ __ ] oh thanks keeps giving the safe and
away
[Laughter]
guys are quick let's draw out you're
good you pump it in first and then you
spoon mama bear and then momen bear has
the baby you guys just sit there until
there's because I'm so [ __ ] cute
I still can't get on with a bear
argument hmm a bear argument the
argument into their old plays the
Goldilocks just moved into the bear
house like the bakery we can all relate
to our next story speaking of books ago
is no sad one oh Carlos muñoz ports huh
37 year old he was a location scout for
Netflix's oh yeah yo narcos oh and here
was found dead oh I know why why could
that fool be exposing the [ __ ] cartel
so they [ __ ] killed where are they
what have you stumbled upon some cartel
business that's my beer peace and
goodness I think that's what happened
that's what a lot of people are
speculating to that maybe he went into
like cartel territory and then they see
this unknown man with a camera because
he was a location scout so I was singing
what oh [ __ ] and then they just killed
him and he woody no they shot him today
did they capture him and then shot him
or like they just shot him on the
premise well his body they just saying
that his body was riddled with bullets
found oh my god greatest car yeah maybe
they straight up through and then they
put him in a car maybe maybe [ __ ]
[ __ ]
he's worked on a lot of projects who
worked on Apocalypto that is so sad
was he going around with a camera yeah
communications go they probably thought
he was like the federales god damn that
sucks dude they're gonna make a movie
about this guy now on narcos yeah I know
why why they got it why did Marcos gotta
play with like fire and [ __ ] like this
is final it's the premise of the show is
playing with fire a hundred percent but
then to send people out into like the
[ __ ] lion's den it's like why where
is not go shot it supposed to be shot in
Colombia yeah but maybe for the next
season they're gonna Mexico well I've
been watching the next one and I haven't
finished it but from what I've seen they
do have do they start going into Mexico
okay see you don't do that yeah just
shoot in Hawaii
palm trees like forest there [ __ ] yeah
so you could cheat it United me like
don't actually go there like what the
[ __ ] that's true
probably it is durgamma you don't
actually go to like TJ did yeah you know
what I mean you go to pretend cheat TJ
yeah he's go to [ __ ] East LA [ __ ] and
you're pretty good right yeah we like
wandered into a desert because they made
a desert location that he wondered like
into like a hidden drugs maybe he got
lost and then yeah he got lost in an
animals shot him animal shot it and yeah
well he was found near the border with
Hildago little dog oh it was in the
municipality of Damascus kalapa that's
where you is you're just making it work
wait you can't even have indigenous
names I can't see oh it's not bad oh
yeah they got like exes with like weird
indigenous in the Mayan language
Mazatlan not ticklin no pyramid
thank you walk on or some stuff like
that that's the one that's that's what I
want to see the pyramids because even
the name Xochitl is like when you read
cuz it's with an X I'm like how the [ __ ]
did you know it's what you but but yeah
that's pretty fun how do you pronounce
xxx 10 and like Oh Hawkins and routine
that's how they have a Mexican so much
better yeah it does yeah
Michiko yeah try that story there was
these robbers that jumped a man here in
California and Gardena actually they're
doing their job
hey that's my city jumpin this guy tryin
to rob them
but then UPS workers came to the rescue
men and brown have arrived
mail delivery guys have been really good
lately yes
where did they have a bad rap I mean
won't even throw in packages of [ __ ] but
they were really cool lately actually
ever wanting to set up a camera to catch
the assault I have delivery guys I keep
throwing my my packages what a [ __ ]
this happened right outside of a UPS
delivery whatever well they came to the
rescue
oh no they already look like they have
to no good was that [ __ ] NWA I know
whose [ __ ] they just dragged in yeah
you're hitting him with a crowbar oh my
god what do they want to take from him
do all oh they're like oh yeah did they
grab anything be sure to ran out I
started taking pictures dude that's
crazy
because what I pictured in my head was
way [ __ ] different it was two guys
with my body type fighting off six guys
with my body type so it was like that
all like out of shape big dudes
it was very anticlimactic I was
picturing you know in my head there were
a lot more fit and you know viral but it
was just like you know eight dudes they
look like me yeah moving your head yeah
it was way different I want to think
that this is how a gang war started and
now Brown is a gang color ups versus
FedEx [ __ ] yeah blue versus brown that's
a New Krypton blood you know though I
don't know if I would have liked helping
that person out though why we know
you're a [ __ ] okay the cool part but
there was like if there was like five or
six you guys I was through ups guys yes
guys to Roberts only three they look
like there was more that's like four
they were reporting I think there was
like three and the credit what they
still yeah then they ended up getting
his backpack these look like a student
on his phone so this man was walking out
of a bank of course yeah and so he was
on his phone they don't report whether
or not these took anything he looked
like a high school kid cuz he had his
backpack on sagging and then he's on his
phone just maybe they've been scoping
him out cuz maybe he was just doing the
drop-offs from like a restaurant they
didn't take his backpack he's probably a
weed guy weed delivery guy you know they
wear backpacks they were hitting him
with the crowbars but the victim wasn't
seriously injured
that's how gay sir he is do that full
[ __ ] Botha [ __ ] huh okay I don't know
I'm second the victim looked like a geek
how do you get head with the crowbar I
get hurt well he wasn't seriously
injured
okay I think you did good my Cardenas
like real when we were shooting [ __ ]
like it we I just walked out so we were
trying to shoot that the area where the
beating happened right the Rodney King
[ __ ] and then when I walked outside
somebody literally just said to me you
were in the wrong neighborhood [ __ ] I
was like what you are though is what it
is it was a girl it was a drive-by
[ __ ] was it called roast
she's like you're in the wrong
neighborhood I probably am here's all
right because I was in like the [ __ ]
attire you know the baggy clothes the
chain and [ __ ] so it didn't look right
and then how does that scream [ __ ] - I
don't know but it was the wrong JK it's
just an insult but then like it's stupid
because Justin was like so our DP was
getting the shot he goes eh make sure
you protect him I'm like who's gonna
protect me like what the [ __ ] so we just
got some nice Brown right back in but it
happened a lot though people people just
don't like people out there man I
remember what races Gardena
predominantly black in Mexican North
Side is mainly black and then well
there's a lot of Asians - but that's
like near the border of Torrance if you
search like Google like a youtube like
Gardena videos a lot of it's like black
on Mexican fights yeah I do I do I go
through the rabbit hole with fights on
on the Internet yeah oh my god right
yeah I'm just like black person next to
you black person's mixing black cover
and if occasionally have an Asian guy in
their high school always had like these
huge riots that like oh I don't know
like it was like a school lockdown huh
50 kids on 50 just black and Mexicans
like going to the Mexicans get in on all
that chickens in my eyes close Mexicans
and agents are very Asian Mexican that
Asians in our area there was no race
riot in black soon so they would get
into a lot of fight and you can easy my
school was so nerdy but they just fought
over a good grades
that's what Julia was saying to it Julie
was saying like in her school she was
like they would make fun of each other
cuz I made a b-minus issue I wish I went
to that school
girl they feet jump people with shittier
grades in them the theme said that to
write like at his school everyone just
got along and it was like all peaceful
yeah that didn't happen or maybe he just
didn't hang out in the crowd that got
picked on or whatever he was telling me
they have like way different beef
because I we don't even have that many
over here so it'd be like Afghans versus
Samoans and stuff so they have their own
beef with light stuff that we're not
yeah but NorCal has like they still have
like they're like some own blood some
own cribs yeah big [ __ ] too
yeah there is a few Samoans at my school
they were so sweet but they were huge
like the Hawaiian girl that said she was
your biggest fan she's 12 and she's tall
I think oh yeah 12 she was like she
wasn't still in junior high yeah she was
really young she was that taller than
here's your up in a softball oh my
that's cool dude let go of my hand
yeah just sounds like [ __ ] like
plastic crunching is [ __ ] oh god man was
it her like older brother or older
sister smaller her brother was smaller
than her he was probably six I hope you
guys enjoyed this video for more please
subscribe to our Channel and you can
check out the last video right here
[Music]